aujourd'hui a déjà fait appel à ces
rencontres vous aider ah c'est vrai oui
c'est ça la c'est quoi le sondage en
fait c'est ça justement qu'il ya des
sondages
non mais c'est la question qui était
posée voilà donc voilà donc le sondage
c'est un français sur trois français sur
quatre
la recette déjà inscrit au moins une
fois sur un site dont on contre une
application
un chiffre en hausse constante par
rapport au précédent d'études est ce que
vous l'avez déjà fait philippe lellouche
non non non non jamais non jamais non
enfin vous pourrez vous avez appuyé leur
en ce moment le mec un peu connue qui
fait ça ouais la balance ton corps c'est
le lendemain voilà mais c'est sûr que
mes mais je suis pas de cette génération
là on fait ça ça a démarré il ya trois
ans mais regardez bal à 20 ans j'en
aurai usées benjamin castaldi vous
rendez compte si vous étiez de cette
génération vous seriez marié 44
[Applaudissements]
moi j'ai fait appel avant quand j'étais
plus jeune j'allais au tribunal dans le
36 15 codes ou là 15 16 ans
voilà tout oui mais c'était un incident
et doit on croyait donc j'avais j'avais
noué une relation sympa avec une femme
ouais et donc du bassin se rencontrent
ouais et gt gt chez elle normand et là
c'était la meuf c'était pandora à laver
des cuissardes en cuir comme ça habille
en léopard
isabelle non
[Rires]
non parce que j'ai des longue histoire
donc est entre gens bien le seul à vous
avez pu être selon moi je préfère à
sécréter souvenirs à la mêlée mais y'a
pas toi jean michel maire a beau eu
plein de fois où je suis encore mais je
suis pas très actif à 17 je rencontre
sur adopteunmec ans que je suis au vip
je suis abonné à vivre vite on a eu
filiale très longue ya 4 5 ans avait
fait une fausse pub d'une parodie
d'adopter un mec ça adopta mer c'est une
pub litres est mort suite à ça il m'a
envoyé une carte d'abonné à vie avec je
peux envoyer des charmes illimitée donc
j'y suis mais malheureusement toutefois
que c'est un fake
et si j'en crois que j'ai essayé j'ai
été viré j'ai la dalle point coop mais
j'étais bien le problème c est qu on est
obligé de mettre sa photo sur un site
comme ça autrement on n'a aucune réponse
et quand médias photos tout le monde
dise espèce de mythe au décès de
remplacer la légende bien à 15
[Rires]
et je suis direct maxime nature kinder
plus sur teen d'heure depuis 3 4 ans
tient qu'au plus haut de ce dossier
juste le prénom mais les mains cette
application parce que rezaï mois et demi
j'ai déjà rencontré quelqu'un non à
trois reprises reprises c'est l'époque
des d'y avoir une petite étincelle qui
allaient se créer la folie n'at elle pas
du doubs et de la folie mais rien ne
s'est passé donc et maintenant j'ai
beaucoup plus de demandes de jeunes
femmes depuis que je fais un peu de
télévision
adacore sincérité ou pas est-ce qu'elles
viennent pour mon image ou bourse que tu
non mais je comprend pas le projet
capillaire un look anglais et un style
capillaire de pente anglaise le chaland
d'oasis au tout ça ah oui non là c'est
encore de fruité et retour vers le futur
le plus attiré le doc on retombe dans le
futur alors arrêtées sur incident oui
bah sur milite elle mais moi il m'est
arrivé de gros problèmes ensuite avec
les sites de rencontre et quand ils vous
ai parlé des projets à cause de mon
physique parce que mon physique vous le
savez plaît énormément hors de france et
figurez-vous que en asie en asie et dans
les pays de l'est de l'ancien empire
soviétique
eh bien ma vie et ma photo pour
illustrer des sites et 15 conteneurs
ah oui mais fait corriger plein de
problèmes avec sa star et celle enlevée
ou pas finalement ta photo grâce à un
avocat
ah ouais ça a duré très longtemps dans
les pays de l'est en asie on rappelle
gilles verdez c'est vraiment c'est une
référence bal des oui c'est le symbole
de long et lui mais c'est vrai c'est fou
mais la médaille ils ont bien des
ophtalmos
mieux encore vous êtes magnifique je
vous dis tous les soirs et c'est vrai
bon là peu coup ce soir je bats comme un
ouf mais ça va vous non forcément dans
télégramme
mais bruxelles mais ce faire marcher ce
top voir pigeon voyageur ça prend du
temps et faire un taux passé non je vais
dire une gentillesse son mari attention
c'est quentin du steak à la maison va
pas chercher de hamburgers ailleurs mois
à travailler ils pas compris les
bouchers votre mari danse et de la bonne
bière ben ouais d'accord merci ça va
mieux avec votre mari ça va bah oui il
ya des pneus neige dont je le ménage en
ce moment
[Rires]